START THINGS OFF WITH ELLER,
AND THAT IS WALL OFF  GOALIE. Y.
BOB: I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE ANY.
OVECHKIN PUTS IT THROUGH THE
CREASE AS IT FLOATS ALL TERRIFIO
THIS WASHINGTON CAPITA
BOB: GAULTIER WITH A SHOT.
SAMSOO
HATHAWAY.
FINDS ATS WAY THROUGH SAMSONOV!
BEAUTIFUL DROP-PASSS IT AND
COMES FOR THE GOALTENDER TO PICK
UP AND WHEN YOU SHOOTS FORWARD.
SWEEPS ONE.
AND HE GUIDES FEHERVARY.
THAT SHOT ON NET BY ROONEY IS S.
LINDGREN SENDS IT ALL THE WAY
DOWN
SAVE MADE WITH THE GLOVE BY
SASA THE
FORECHECK IN THE FIRST PERIOD
AND THEN A GOOD JOB ON THE RUSHE
NET GOES TO HIS
BACKHAND.
ALTHOUGH THE FOURTH
LINE, UP 4 SIDE.
YOU CAN SEE THE SHAFT.
THAT'S WHY HE DID
GLOVE SAVE BY SAMSONOV! SCORE!
ANGELA PHREN YEAR GOT A PIECE OF
ABLE TO GET BODY POSITION ON
GOAL.
START OF THIS THIRD PERIOD, THIS
IS A CRITICAL POWER PLAY FORSEEF
THE NET
REBOUND, OF DUB --
TROUBLE
MOVESH SERVED., BLUE SHIRT. PREF
RYAN REAVES AND HE HAS BEEN A
BUSISI, ONE-TIMER IN THE
KUZNETSOV.
ONE